how's it going brahs I got my duck you
bros have made the maps like studious in
the last episode I asked you bros to
make me a bunch of maps and here they
are I'm ready to be blown away by race
oh it's on so this is a racing track
that your bros bill for me okay well
let's see if I can actually finish it
without falling on a studious Oh God can
I front flip yes yes I can
no no no no no no yeah break it down now
to me now Donald break it down to me not
Donald thanks one just says fabulous I
assume it's fabulous Gary out in the
land of fabulous let's ma yourself a
little bit in case we run into trouble
Oh God Oh God
I can't drive hey what a slide all right
my minions test out if it's safe he
really wants to go let me ride please
you go go well yeah let's do Deus whoa
goodbye
no regrets
uh-oh take a hide this is a small step
for duck but a giant step for duck oh no
no no no no there we go
Wow I believe I can duck I
oh you tricked companies matter so weird
you bros confuse me sometimes
saddle up you are clear to end it
welcome to Pizza Planet oh my god
I'm fine oh my god it's awesome let's do
this matheus whoa yeah Oh God do a
front-flip
almost almost edit that one time this is
look working out for me all right now
front flip no I did this is my house
alright hey yeah go in
Felix house ha ha ha alright well I
guess I take my private helicopter over
to YouTube land alright Rin YouTube
headquarters
now what let's go in here travel to
Minecraft what Omega it's Minecraft
alright let's try this wagon thing so
Rock Me mamma front flap nailed it
I wonder if this cart has a boost that
would make sense oh god oh god oh god oh
god is that a creeper
that's a creeper isn't it yeah it is
whoa oh no I blew it
oh oh oh
oh now the creeper damn you creeper oh
jet pack juicy yet or not I don't care
slender uh-oh this is just as I
remembered it creepy house ah ah ah
their words jump scares stop we all know
son it would be a lot better if you had
a car so why not where you transform
whoa badass how slender should have been
right here on the Buddha by Channel
yes the satisfaction brofist ha ha ha ha
all right price I hope you enjoyed this
video I'm gonna drive up to the sensit
Thank You brothers for making these
awesome mask for me it's super fun to
play please leave a like if you enjoyed
watching and I'll see Bruce as always in
the next damn it
I press stay awesome